as a lawyer seeing what's happening to
the Tate Brothers is just so so enraging
crime that's preposterous that is
contrary to the fundamental principles
of international law and human rights
you could actually tell your loyalty to
the principles of Justice when you see
how you want it applied to those who you
disagree with the normal case with a
normal individual I believe the Tates
would absolutely be out it's actually an
insult to women
it's an insult to women it's in fact
even if I disagreed with everything they
stood for I would stand by this position
because as a lawyer I took an oath to
protect Justice that's gone too much and
it's a disservice to the many many women
that are actual victims of abuse
regardless of who it is regardless I as
a lawyer
would never tolerate the idea that a
human being can be locked up by the full
force and power of a damn bankman freed
this guy allegedly was involved in a
scheme that but then they end up he ends
up accepting Islam he ends up accepting
Islam and then he comes back and now
he's in jail does this have anything to
do with his decision to take Islam as a
way of life we've been told that they're
out to kill us all assalamualaikum
brothers and sisters we went to the
streets to ask Americans about Islam
here's what they said do you know
anything about Islam No do you know
anything about Islam No sadly do you
know anything about Islam uh not really
do you know anything about Islam
no I'm sorry you know what Islam means
Islam uh no we've been told that uh
they're out to kill us all right that's
what you've been told that Muslims are
out to kill you all
well that's what they say on TV
anything
I know it's in the Middle East isn't it
well then you can have four wives
brothers and sisters as you can see
there are so many Americans who don't
know about Islam we need your help to
change that help us to build the dean
Center the first mega dawa Center in
America click to donate right now may
God Almighty Allah reward all of you
foreign Tate
it's all over the news
and we want to get to the bottom of
things try to understand things a little
bit better they're still detained not
charged and who better to give us a
better understanding than a lawyer so
someone who has
experience in this field in this realm
we're at the law office
of Shibley and Shibley yeah Muslim legal
[Applause]
let me into the future
[Music]
and I was explaining how much respect I
have for the faith
this one legal so you're also a trial
lawyer a civil rights lawyer is uh can
you give us a little bit of value yeah
at my Law Firm you know I did about
decade of civil rights defense for the
Muslim Community at him they're running
one of the largest American Muslims of
Rights organizations and through Allah's
Grace now we have a private practice
which really aims to providing Islamic
ethical quality representation to the
Muslim Community and help them meet
their legal needs in an Islamic ethical
way we do everything from Islamic Estate
Planning and wills to marriages and
divorces hopefully in the Sharia
compliant manner uh to business
contracts and we do quite a bit of civil
rights work and criminal defense in fact
just within the last couple months we've
had numerous Muslims in the State of
Florida who were wrongfully arrested or
charged with crimes they did not commit
and by getting involved early Gathering
the evidence and providing it with the
process to the prosecution able to get
the charges completely dismissed but
what does that teach you that teaches
you that in innocent people get arrested
and charged all the time and you need to
have a strong legal system in place in
order to be able to liberate them and I
think that's why as a lawyer seeing
what's happening to the Tate Brothers is
just so so enraging and uh just
disgusting yeah I wanted to get your
perspective as an attorney a lawyer
practicing for many years
these cases that you've tried this is in
the United States this is a little bit
different because it's in Romania now
sure what we've had we've had cases
International I mean one of the you've
had International absolutely and we were
able to use the media and political
pressure to liberate those who are even
wrongfully arrested overseas and and we
see that the US government has the power
to do that I mean you look at most
recently a case obviously I wasn't
involved in but of a basketball player
who you know flew into Russia with THC
oil which is illegal over there frankly
it's illegal in the U.S and that's
that's a crazy thing I want to discuss
but the US government put forward its
full influence and power to demand that
she be released and she was convicted
she was facing years in hard labor and
the U.S government was able to get her
after a conviction released and back to
the U.S meanwhile though we're locking
up people for the same crimes here
domestically
let's get to the evidence put emotions
to the side it's going to be very
emotional for a lot of people and a lot
of people you know are on one side of
the fence or the other but many people
are also now who are objectively looking
at this and looking at the evidence
they're seeing that okay it doesn't hold
weight you even had so many different
people coming out and saying okay they
haven't been charged charge them already
if they did something wrong okay charge
them persecute them but they're being
detained without charges now and now the
evidence let's go over that let's look
at the evidence and then you as an
attorney you should give your
perspective right so so let's look at
the situation right now so far these
brothers have been arrested since
December they're going on three months
in a Romanian jail
um with completely abhorrent conditions
without being charged with a single
crime mind you the brothers have been
wiretapped at least for the 10 months
prior you know they've had the eyes of
the world on them and clearly the eyes
of the Romanian government and the fact
that they've been spying on them for 10
months they've had them in jail for
three months and they could potentially
under Romanian law they could
potentially hold them for up to 180 days
without being charged with a crime
that's preposterous that is contrary to
the fundamental principles of
international law and human rights
governments should never have the
ability and the authority to detain
individuals human beings without charges
for such a long period of time it's
Preposterous it's it's unheard of and uh
it's it's just uh crazy and the fact
that so many people even in the US are
okay with it just because they disagree
with the Tates on some political views
or social views that doesn't matter the
principles of Liberty
are Paramount for all of us and if any
one of us see you could actually tell
your loyalty to the principles of
Justice when you see how you want it
applied to those who you disagree with
if you're okay with those whom you
disagree with having their rights
violated then what you've done is you've
destroyed your own rights as well that's
a good point you know as and as a lot of
great Americans have said listen I may
disagree with your views but I will die
Defending Your Right to to say it
because if you lose your freedom to say
something I disagree with then we've all
lost our freedom and this is what we've
seen with the Tates you know the Tates
uh I mean arguably the most famous
people in the world I mean certainly
Andrew Tate was the most Googled person
and you know very very soon after he
publicly Embraces Islam starts sharing
quotes of the Prophet Muhammad starts
talking about the beauty of our Dean
all of a sudden he's arrested on
allegedly years old charges which just
don't hold water so so let's talk about
it let's start about where we are right
now how we got here and what that means
for the principles of liberty and
justice for all Humanity yeah if if
that's just a coincidence what you said
that he recently just recently accepted
Islam and does this have anything to do
with it before we even get to that let's
look at the evidence sure that supposed
evidence that's there starting with if
you as an attorney if you had evidence
now or even the prosecution here if
there's evidence that can exonerate your
defendant they're obliged to take that
they have to turn it over they have to
they have to make it accessible to the
defense and frankly they have to review
it and that's why we've had so much
success in the U.S yeah like I mentioned
you over the last year we've had
multiple cases of actually Community
leaders imams sisters that run charity
organizations in the U.S either getting
arrested or charged with false crimes
and alhamdulillah they contacted our
office we were able to review the
evidence presenter the prosecution and
the prosecution had to review it and
when they reviewed it because they're
sincere they thanked us they said we
weren't aware of this we're dropping all
charges that's where now in Romania it's
a little bit different it's completely
different the not only are they not
turning over any exculpatory or
vindicating evidence it seems that they
are actually actively trying to stop
that evidence from being made public
certainly they're not reviewing it
certainly they're not working with the
defense towards truth it's very clear
it's a politically different situation
so let's talk about the evidence so
because I think uh when you see what's
out there and you see the conditions
they're in it's it's mind-blowing so the
facts are again these brothers have been
in jail since December and we're going
three months up to 180 days that they
could be uh held
um we've seen a complete silence amongst
the Western governments that claim to be
proponents of Liberty and Justice let's
go ahead and look at objectively the
evidence that's presented and then one
by one if it carries weight right I mean
and regardless this is what I have to
understand regardless of who it is
regardless I as a lawyer
would never tolerate the idea that a
human being can be locked up by the full
force and power of a government
for not just one day one week one month
but now three months without being
charged without being charged that is
abhorrent I don't care if you're accused
of murder
of terrorism of rape the power of the
government to incarcerate and take away
the greatest thing which is fundamental
human Liberty
it cannot exist without due process
without Justice without evidence which
should result in charges and the fact
that they haven't been able to charge
them for this long I mean if they're
really so guilty bring forward even
lesser charges and then you could always
increase the charges down the road but
the fact that they haven't been able to
throw any charges on them and listen we
live in the U.S can I tell you how many
times people have been charged
and still they were innocent let's talk
about how many times people have been
convicted and they were innocent I mean
in the US we saw the case of Adnan Saeed
where are all those people who stood by
Adnan said for years why are they not
speaking was convicted allegedly of
murdering his girlfriend
and now I don't know is it a decade or
two later was just released exonerated
um it reminds us that listen innocent
people get arrested innocent people get
charged innocent people even get
convicted and the fact of the Tate
Brothers they haven't even been able to
charge them and they're holding them now
for three months it's an attack on
Liberty for all Humanity the strongest
evidence that they have let's take a
look right and he was an attorney now
give us your perspective well first of
all two of the alleged victims that were
on the victims list publicly came out
saying what are you talking about we're
not victims you know and the
government's response is oh you're
brainwashed
and they gave them that diagnosis
without even any mental health
professionals speaking with them so it's
like they're just ready on their defense
points they they're so sloppy in what
they're doing that they're putting
people on the victims list that are
openly saying to the world and on social
media hey we are not victims Tate didn't
do anything wrong to us you know do not
include us in this prosecution we have
nothing to do with it and they've gone
above and beyond they've gone they've
made videos they've come out absolutely
very vocally speaking up and that's
actually an insult to women
it's an insult to woman it's taking away
the mind and the agency in the authority
of a woman that woman listen you're too
dumb to know if you're a victim that's
what that's what it spells out actually
that's an insult to woman where's all
the woman rights activists not speaking
out you know women have agency they have
authority they have they have the power
to to have consent or not and when a
woman comes out and says hey I'm not a
victim and for the government to say no
no you're so stupid you're brainwashed
you don't know what you're talking about
it's an insult to women everywhere it's
an insult to Liberty everywhere so
that's the first issue is right off the
bat when you have the list of alleged
victims at least two of them have spoken
out very vocally saying we're not and
they're going to say we're not going to
listen to you you're wrong you are a
victim whether you like it or not and
that just is an insult to women
everywhere that's the first thing the
second thing I mean the explosive and
you've covered this so well the
explosive text messages between two of
the alleged victims so now we got
another two right that you're you're
bringing up now another two with a
history of accusing those they don't
like I mean I believe one of these women
that she got mad with her mom so she
made accusations against her her mother
her own mother she got in a bad
relationship she made accusations
against and she knows listen we live in
this metoo world where if you're a woman
and you don't like someone just run your
mouth make up some BS and you'll gather
a lot of support and that's gone too
much and it's a disservice to the many
many women that are actual victims of
abuse you know and my office has
represented uh so many women that are
actual victims of domestic violence of
rape of abuse and they're so
disheartened by those that loudly make
up such claims just to gain an advantage
uh to gain advantage in a divorce to
extort someone for money whereas the
true victims are actually often too
scared to speak out and often afraid
people won't believe them but it's
because of thugs like these people who
want to take advantage for their own
personal agenda so so you look at these
two women now we it's not just he said
she said we have their own words we have
the WhatsApp conversations where they're
saying they're going to get an Oscar for
their acting where they say man your
acting is so good yes I've been
practicing where they're celebrating
that they're you know colluding with
each other to frame the Tates and how
rich and famous and popular they're
going to be even getting their own
Netflix special so we have that evidence
I mean that in and of itself again shows
uh that the
that these women clearly are conspiring
to commit a crime to falsely accuse
someone and to get that for their own
personal benefit I mean that by itself
now because these are the two key
Witnesses right of the case I believe
just this by itself should be enough to
exonerate them to have them set them
free I think absolutely it should be
enough to generate at least have them
released pending any other concrete
evidence to arrest them because even in
the U.S when you're I mean look at Sam
bankman freed this guy allegedly was
involved in a scheme that that you know
resulted in the theft and embezzlement
of billions billions of dollars he's out
living in his parents home right now and
said you know he's got access to God
knows how much crypto wealth that's
hidden that's untraceable you know and
yet he's free to live in his parents
home pending the investigation and yet
the Tates with such flimsy accusations
against them have been locked up in
horrid conditions for months again I
don't care if you like or hate the Tates
in fact even if I disagreed with
everything they stood for I would stand
and by this position because as a lawyer
I took an oath to protect Justice for
All humanity and I know that when those
uh even that we disagree with when they
lose their rights we've all lost our
rights and and the timing of it which we
need to talk more about the timing of
the arrest is just it's just shocking
but let's get more into the point so if
you have the WhatsApp messages where
they are admitting to conspiring to set
up the Tates right and and that they're
such good actors and they're going to
make so much money and fame off of this
now I've seen where people they go into
some of the messages now that they're
having with their their mother but it
seems like with those when you look at
the transcripts they're like they're
they're coming in and deceiving their
mother because now they're you know
saying one thing and then this
conversation happens later on right
right right and their mother was
freaking out and she doesn't know the
truth from the falsehood and it's just a
mess there's a lot of manipulation a lot
of manipulation and this is a problem we
have to talk about this problem there is
a theme
in particular in 2023 now
of certain angry women who don't get
what they want who manipulate and abuse
the system for their own benefit and a
lot of us are enabling that and it's
destructive and you know what they
ultimately pay the price I mean I do
family law yeah I can't tell you how
many times I've seen spouses come out
with the craziest accusations and in
Waging War against their ex-spouse
knowing they're going to get support and
they'll get some support initially but
then as the time wears off they're like
what have I done I've destroyed myself
I've lied you know I've manipulated and
and usually the it catches up with them
and usually they regret it and I've seen
this happen again and again but we live
in a culture that enables that and and
what we don't understand is it's not
just harming those that are accused it's
really even destroying the accusers and
their families how does it work because
these two women one is from the U.S the
other one is from UK right they say the
Moldova sure sure so now and there's
actual criminal investigation against
because you got to remember this all
started back I believe in April yes
where the Tates home was raided based
again on false accusations the tape it
actually started back then correct and
they actually count and nobody's
arrested then again there was no reason
to arrest them but what dictates it is
actually countered with criminal charges
an investigation against the accusers
and because there has to be
accountability you cannot simply falsely
accuse someone potentially destroy their
life so another piece of evidence so we
spoke about two of the victims alleged
victims coming out and saying we're not
victims and the government said be quiet
you know who you're talking about we
spoke about now two of them conspiring
to bring down the Tates to gain Fame and
in their own words again having had done
this before having a pattern of doing
this third is we have the CCTV footage
the security footage this is very
important here this footage here
absolutely which prosecution currently
is not you the prosecution is taken and
is refusing to release it I believe they
haven't even given it to the defense if
I'm not mistaken but that really
destroys their case because again it
shows the woman coming in and out freely
of the compound it shows the Dynamics of
the environment the relationship and I
think it really destroys their case you
can't be uh captured you know and not
free to leave when you're sitting there
laughing and joking and just coming and
going about as you please again it's
just a very common theme of of people
consensually entering entering into
whatever kind of relationships whether
playtonic or otherwise then trying to
take advantage trying to extort trying
to get money and when they don't get
what they want saying you know what I'm
gonna I'm gonna say whatever I want to
say and the World's Gonna believe me
because guess what hashtag believe her
hashtag me too and it's a shame
especially when Muslims support that
because where would you I'm not
comparing anyone to anyone but we have
to take historic lessons where would you
be with hashtag believe her hashtag me
too the Quran itself speaks about this
disease
or false accusations
right against people in a position of
influence and success you know the story
of us I'm very clear the man was falsely
accused of rape
falsely accused of fornication again we
can't continue to blindly support uh
accusations without evidence and and
stand by as people literally lose their
Liberty this doesn't really look good
for the Romania does it at the end I
mean I think it's clear Romanian justice
system is a joke is very corrupt uh
politically driven and is certainly not
a country for the rest of history now I
mean what are the people going to
remember
humiliation an unjust country and I
believe it shows how easily there are
politicians and their leaders maybe
bought out yeah and I'm sure most uh a
lot of Romanians are speaking out also
you can see the news come forward so
there's a few there is it can it be
politically molded by one party there or
you know I think it's a slap in the face
to public freedom because I think what
they want to show is look
it doesn't matter if you're the most
famous man in the world if we want to
get you we can and it's going to have a
chilling effect or that's what they want
it to if they want to have a chilling
effect to keep people quiet to keep
people in line to keep people promoting
whatever agendas they have and when you
speak out they want to say we don't care
for the most famous person we'll get you
and I think that's the scary thing and
we cannot give in to that we have to
continue to be fearless and courageous
we need to all speak out you know
there's people actually would advise me
not to speak out because oh the Tates
are too controversial but listen I more
than anyone firsthand know what it's
like to be falsely accused and see that
those who make the accusations in the
end they're just really destroying
themselves and Allah himself promises do
not think it is bad for you it is good
for you when Believers face Injustice
they will always come out on top and I
do believe Allah
will will put good in this for the Tate
Brothers absolutely what else do we have
so moving on you have the CCTV footage
hasn't been released it shows them
coming in and out completely destroys
the case and the accusations just stop
there for a moment this is for people
understand this camera is all over the
house correct watching people and if
you're doing something illegal you
certainly wouldn't want to record it
it's kind of like uh those TV shows
reality shows right that you imagine
Brother Big Brother yeah so you have
these shows with the camera's all over
and now this is what the prosecution
doesn't want to use as evidence right if
what they're saying is true they would
want to release that yeah because it
should solidify it's a game now it's
correct okay it's not about Justice
correct and finally frankly you have the
social media of the alleged victims
themselves it shows them vacationing and
traveling and having fun and being free
or even you know after when they were
allegedly uh uh victims you know it just
destroys their case and I've seen that
because again I first hand witnessed you
know a woman will claim to be locked up
and beaten and abused by her husband
meanwhile her social media shows her
traveling the world first class and the
crazy thing is p people will ignore
their social media ignore the facts and
just they want to believe they they want
to support this idea that yes the men
are bad and and women can can never lie
and then you you look at the facts and
the reality when the dust settles and
people often have regrets and that's why
Allah says verify do not blindly believe
anything look there's hope for all
people I don't want to just by bringing
what I'm going to say next is look if if
a person has been through everything in
life and they chose the worst path in
life you know there's always hope for
that person even if that person was a
stripper a prostitute which in this case
they are that's who the accusers are so
they're in this world this realm and we
don't want Injustice to happen to
anybody and that person in Islam you
have that prostitute who fed the the dog
the water to the dog I love forgave her
and gave her Paradise right so those
women also we want good for them for
guidance for them and to change their
lives around right to speak the truth
you know not to perpetuate lies and
misinformation and in this situation
this is not like someone if you look at
who the people are are this is this is
actually does this carry weight now when
you're in a situation like this and
you're defending a case or anything do
you bring up you know the profession
their job you know that you have someone
here is one is is a prostitute the other
one is a pole dance stripper or you know
I think more important than their job
which I think it's important to
understand context is their history
their history a combined with their
profession they combined with have they
do they have a history of going after uh
successful men yeah and extorting them
and then accusing them when they don't
get what they want you know if the same
individual somehow has allegedly been
you know targeted by multiple wealthy
men and all these men have raped them
yeah and and okay and she's come out
again and again with these accusations
you know maybe she's the one doing the
plotting and that's why I appreciate the
example in the last episode which was
like the whole you know the opposite of
the lover boy uh condition right where
they come up I mean they know what
they're doing you know they're they're
presenting themselves as lovers to these
men and and that they cherish them that
they genuinely love them
to get in their Circle to benefit from
being within that Circle to live the
luxury Lifestyles the nice restaurants
the Jets you know the travels the
vacations the nice watches and then uh
usually there comes a point where they
just want Cold Hard Cash you know they
extort them Hey listen give you know pay
up or I'm gonna start you know yeah and
this and this and this is another Trend
that we're saying I mean it's wrong when
men do it but also you have a woman who
manipulate both both sides both sides do
it and listen as Muslims we're not
pro-men or pro-woman we are pro-justice
and Allah commands us speak out for
justice and again what concerns me about
this case is it reflects everything
that's wrong with a culture that wants
to believe or disbelieve uh individuals
simply based on their gender men lie
woman lie men can be truthful women can
be truthful not everyone is perfect we
all have our sins and our shortcomings
and we may have disagreements on
different things but again you cannot
disregard the principles of due process
and Justice and I believe leave the Tate
case is a classic example of the
disregard of the principles of Human
Rights and Justice and again which we
didn't dive into yet
when did they decide to bring the world
down so we're down here with looking at
the other yeah I mean these are the key
the key the key pieces to to point out
so if this this now if was something
that you were defending Prosecuting on
either side you look at is this
something that would just be here in the
United States just pretty much thrown
out I mean if I was in the U.S if this
was in the U.S if I was representing the
Tates we would immediately
prepare sworn affidavits from the
uh the woman who who were alleged
victims but who were not victims who
said we are not
uh you know emphasizing that they are
not victims uh we would supplement that
with records of the WhatsApp
conversations with whatever CCTV footage
is there and we would actually uh ask
that the the state itself dropped the
charges completely and if not then we
would demand release on bond
uh until formal charges are brought and
even then that the client should be free
and able to be free uh pending a
conviction I think look the problem is
this isn't a normal case where the
normal rules apply quite frankly any
lawyer who tells you that is BSN okay
but if this was a normal case with a
normal individual I believe the Tates
would absolutely be out I don't think
they wouldn't even face charges not not
when the evidence is that that we can in
fact the evidence is a sculptor that
evidence actually vindicates them you
know because it's one thing you you
can't prove that you didn't do something
but you can prove that the woman were
free to come and go as they please
vis-a-vis the the footage you can prove
that they had the intention to set up
the Tates vis-a-vis their own words you
can prove that the the prosecutors and
the government was going above and
beyond to set these people up even to
place
people who weren't victims by their own
admission as victimsless so those are
all provable and that would be enough I
believe in a just system that is blind
to to have the Tates released but again
this isn't about the evidence now is
this conveniently happening that just
recently and let's get to this part here
recently looked back in was it April
that they were
wiretapping they were investigating them
they brought them in they released them
so then they end up he ends up accepting
Islam he ends up accepting Islam and
then he comes back and now he's in jail
does this have anything to do with his
decision to take Islam as a way of life
I think that played a major role I mean
again
they've waited so long you know the the
the alleged incidents uh in question I
mean are are quite old
um the fact that the government chose to
wait uh to to really try to bring down
his world when he's speaking out proudly
as a Muslim and Europe has its
tremendous history of islamophobia
um and and I think they're scared of the
power and the influence that Islam has
and they see other people following
Tate's footsteps and embracing Islam
just just recently we read about another
person who was very popular actually in
the islamophobic side and in the far
right side embracing Islam
um I think it should raise a lot of
concern for us at the minute he becomes
Muslim and starts sharing Hadith and
starts speaking and start learning his
faith you know uh they come out with
their full force against him again I
believe they're trying to have a
chilling effect and and you know they're
trying to prove a point saying listen we
can shut down the most influential
person in the world if we want
um it's it's troubling did you follow
the Loon case it seems similar in a way
that there was something are you
familiar with what happened with this
Christ that he ended up getting charged
with something that happened years
before his conversion he accepted Islam
and then they ended up uh arresting him
this is a common theme I mean right now
to be very Frank I think there is an
organized orchestrated effort
to try down to try to take down
um
male Muslim leadership
uh really in this country and globally I
mean
I think those that that can be seen to
represent masculine Muslim men in
positions of leadership
are seen as a threat because we stand
against everything that Society now
worships
you know from uh just godlessness and
Atheism
to extreme toxic feminism that is
leading to ridiculous amounts of divorce
and family problems to support of
deviant Lifestyles uh that had brought
about the wrath of Allah for previous
Nations
um you know I I think traditional
masculine Muslim men or those that could
become that because it Tate had just
embraced Islam right so he's definitely
not a scholar definitely not a Muslim
leader per se he's an influential
individual who Embrace Islam and could
be on the path as he studies the Deen as
he reforms as he changes as he grows to
play a positive role so there's an
organized effort to to harm them and I
see that in the U.S even in particular
as well whether it's through false
accusations through criminal charges uh
through random articles I mean it just
it happens again and again and we want
to I think destroy the idea of righteous
proper Pious male leadership and part of
that is also because we have false
standards I mean we expect and think
people are to be perfect no people are
to be human everybody has their ups and
downs and their strengths but we should
all be given the benefit of the doubt we
should take the good leave the bed and
remember the principles that we want to
apply to us which is we're all innocent
until proven guilty have you seen some
of these arguments or somebody's attack
coming from Muslims who will say oh
you're defending someone who's X Y and Z
who is involved in this that oh
absolutely and this is these are things
from his past sure sure I mean it's
there's so much toxicity in in regards
to having these kinds of conversations
and and people want to take some of the
and to be frank Tate's done some
horrible things in his past I'll be very
Frank with that you know what I'm saying
I mean running some of the businesses
certainly we're not Islamic whether it's
gambling whether it's involving females
there's things that we as Muslims
absolutely reject but I also believe as
he's going on his path as Islam he
himself would absolutely reject you know
Islam purifies it destroys what came
before and what we want to do is we want
to be
barriers to God's mercy to humanity that
only those who are with us and like us
and agree with us should have God's
mercy and we forget God's mercy
encompasses all things and on that point
out I do want to share one of my
favorite Hadith because it's a lesson
for all of us look whatever Tate did in
his past
doesn't come anywhere close to what was
she who did we all know why she did
Washi was an assassin he was hired to
assassinate the uncle of the prophet
Muhammed
and he did so and then he desecrated his
body and we know how close Hamza was to
the prophet sallam so what she
eventually he realized the truth he
wanted to become Muslim and so he went
to the prophets I said he said listen
the Quran says believers do not commit
sure don't worship other than Allah I've
worshiped Idols the Quran says Believers
don't fornicate I fornicated the Quran
says Believers don't kill the innocent
and I've killed the innocent I killed
your uncle what hope is there for me to
become Muslim by and far washi's done
worse than what any of us including Tate
could ever do you know from the murder
to the to the fornication you name it he
did it he did it all he did it all and
yet he went to the prophet saying I want
to repent now the prophet saws said
listen you killed my uncle get out of
here there's no mercy for you that's
what we would have done maybe if we love
our uncle we don't want to see his
killer go to paradise but the prophet I
said was a mercy to all creation he
transcended even these personal
differences and the political
differences he waited till the
Revelation came and then Allah revealed
the verse yes believers do not kill do
not fornicate do not commit shirk
and whoever does that will get a
terrible punishment except for those who
repent and believe and do righteous
Deeds not only will Allah forgive them
but he will replace their evil with
righteousness
how about the man who killed 99 and then
exactly you got this beautiful situation
beautiful story and you know what the
story she doesn't finish why she
actually didn't jump on at that moment
because he said these are too many
conditions okay I will believe I will
repent but how do I know my good deeds
will make up for it so then Allah
revealed a second verse of Mercy saying
Allah does not forgive shirk but he
forgives anything besides that to
whomever he wants and again why she
didn't jump on it he said too many
conditions how do I know Allah wants to
forgive me
and then the verse came tell my servants
who wronged themselves do not give up
hope in the mercy of Allah Allah
forgives all the sins altogether
so that is the mercy of Allah he can
forgive even the worst of people he can
forgive the person he went from being
cursed for killing the uncle the prophet
so I said lemon being a fornicator and
being a murderer to being Allah be
pleased with him because he became us a
hobby so why are we trying to stop
Allah's Mercy from each other when
somebody becomes Muslim even if we
disagree with their past we ought to
welcome them and frankly regardless of
the religion when their rights are
trampled upon we all have to stand
vocally against that because if it's
their rights today it could be our
rights tomorrow if one and then you had
that example of the man who killed 99
people then he went and he ended up that
story is just 99. he literally killed
murder you cannot get worse than murder
you know in Islam we have Allah's rights
and human rights and some of the
scholars have written that in many
circumstance human rights are actually
more dangerous more critical than
Allah's rights because Allah if you
violate his rights if you don't worship
him if you ignore him he's not hurt in
the least yeah you know what I'm saying
but human beings
we are limited so if you oppress me if
you hurt me I'm caused harm so you can't
just worship Allah and hurt me you know
what I'm saying and yet this person did
the work committed murder 99 people went
to a scholar said Can Allah forgive me
and the guy said he had to cancel
culture you know and if anybody deserves
cancel culture to be somebody who killed
99 people so you can't even blame him
but he said what you and I would say bro
you killed 99 people you know what hope
is there what what you and I may say
right if we didn't know better so you
know what he's like well if I killed 99
I'm going to hell anyway what's another
one so he killed him too killed 100
people
and then he truly genuinely regretted it
he went to the other he went to the
other person who was wise and he said to
him I've killed a hundred
is there any hope for me and the person
said what can stand between you and the
mercy of Our Lord
but you can't just say you're sorry you
have to take meaningful change you have
to travel go to this you committed all
the sins in this city go to this other
get away from these bad friends get away
from the Bad Company what we say and we
say we say in Arabic
the friend pulls you know the prophet
saws said that we're all in the religion
of our friends and our Companions and
this is the amazing thing by the way
with Tate what I noticed is when he
became Muslim
he's hanging out with other Muslims he's
going to the meship he's starting to
talk with different Scholars being in
righteous step by step step by step you
know we put such false standards for
people but he started to take those
steps of change so anyway this guy was
told you have to go to the city of the
righteous so he starts
traveling to the city of the righteous
and on his journey what happens we know
he passes away
so now the Angels come one of mercy and
one of Wrath the mercy wants to pull him
to Paradise the Wrath wants to take him
to Allah's you know to curse and
Punishment and they're arguing right the
the the mercy the angel of Wrath and
Punishment listen he killed 99 100
people now we got to take him the angels
of Mercy said no he repented we got to
take him so Allah sends an angel to
judge between them and the angel says
measure from the two cities if he's
closer to the bad City
take him back to take him towards
Allah's displeasure and if he's closer
to the good City take him to the city of
righteousness which city was he closer
to he just left he was close to the one
he just left which means he should go
towards Allah's punishment but look how
merciful Allah is he told the bad City
move farther he told the good City moved
closer Allah moved two cities to forgive
a sinner who killed a hundred people and
then he was close to the city of mercy
and he was forgiven look
Allah calls you to forgive you let's not
let's not put any barriers between us
and Allah's mercy and others and Allah's
Mercy let's love for others what we love
for ourselves let's wish good for
everyone and this is the sad thing
because I notice there's a hatred by
which we talk about others you know it's
just people there's a lot of hatred I
mean even if the person is as bad as you
say wish for him good wish for him a
sincere repentance wish for him that he
becomes a source of good for Humanity is
that healing that's going to help that
person to go ahead and get to a level
that they're going to leave off all of
these evil that's it that's become the
best uh person that they can in humanity
and that's the track record of Islam it
literally takes drunks fornicators
polytheists and makes them amongst the
most righteous and Pious you look at
Islamic history some of the most
righteous men in Muslim history before
Islam were Highway robbers literally
we're Highway robbers but they witnessed
how those they robbed were behaving and
their connection with their religion
they repented and that's uh you have
people who are really close to Andrew
Tate some call him his manager manager
who also accepted I believe brother
Julius mashallah he's uh someone who
also accepted Islam you could see him
really taking Islam serious and you know
praying in the Masjid and he's talking
about also how uh Andrew Tate is also
starting to anything he comes into he
really takes serious and now him being
you can see because now it would have
been much harder for him to connect with
the Quran sure and now this is kind of
you know Allah and Allah's wisdom
inshallah Allah uses him for the Deen
for the dawah that he's sitting him down
and having him connect with the Quran
and until he gets out he's much stronger
there's benefit everything that happens
to the Believers is of benefit and we
certainly have to believe that and we do
and I've seen it in my own life Allah
says don't think it's bad for you
there's always good we just have to keep
that connection with Allah you know
Yusuf Ali Islam was falsely accused
thrown in jail and how was he described
by his companions we see you amongst the
righteous the time in jail gave him an
opportunity
to manifest his righteousness to display
his righteousness and then he was
liberated and likewise when he was
liberated in a position of power his
brothers came to him didn't know it was
his brother but also described him as of
the righteous and that's how we
Believers have to be righteous whether
in good times or bad times the prophesy
said the first people to enter Paradise
are those who are thankful to Allah in
good times and bad times that's the
nature of this world so as we close out
tell me now what would you think is a
way forward to facilitate some kind of
because obviously in this Romanian
system there's seems like
that Justice is not happening is not
going to happen public pressure you
talked about you had some success where
you put the media so we're using the
little means that we have others can
also and then also political pressure so
a few things I mean first before I jump
into that I really want to emphasize a
point for everybody that's watching
because Michelle I think you have a
great audience many are Muslim many are
not and those that are watching that
aren't Muslim sometimes may think Islam
isn't for them because they've committed
or they commit all these sins that the
Quran advises against and I want people
to understand the Quran advises you
against these sins to protect you to
make you the best version of yourself
and you know what no matter how many of
these sins you commit every time you
repent to Allah Allah is willing to
forgive you and give you a freshly what
I want people to understand Islam is not
just for the righteous we think that to
be Muslim grow out your beard go for
omra give in charity it must mean you're
righteous and if you have any sins and
shortcomings then you're a hypocrite for
even doing those righteous things that's
a satanic way of thinking the pure way
of thinking is the reality is Islam is
for each and every one of us it is for
the Sinners the prophet himself said my
intercession is for the people of major
sins amongst my um never let your sins
and weakness keep you away from Allah
drive you to Allah whatever sins
shortcomings you have let that be
motivation the prophet said Good Deeds
erase the bad Deeds so Islam is for all
of us it is for the Sinners don't think
you're a hypocrite because you do a b c
sin and now you're thinking of becoming
one slim or you're Muslim and you're
going to the mosque or you're going for
umrah listen you're not a hypocrite
you're a human struggling on their
journey to Allah and that's what Allah
asks of us so keep it up don't be
hopeless in terms of this
um you know one of the cases you had
asked me about International cases and
we didn't get to get into the detail but
we had a case where the Israelis beat up
a Palestinian teenager from Tampa and
they locked them up and they made his
face purple and blue and this is
something that happens normally to the
Palestinians at the hands of the
Israelis and you know what alhamdulillah
we exposed that video in the National
media here we create a firestorm viewed
millions of times exposing what the
Israelis did and alhamdul within a few
days we actually had them released from
the prison and we had them on a flight
back to the US and they testified before
Congress uh and the White House even
that was straightforward I tell you when
we met with the White House officials
they said this was made possible by the
media Firestorm you created
unfortunately I think what's working to
the Romanian officials Advantage is that
because uh you know Tate's been so
demonized by the by the left and the
left has a lot of influence in the U.S
media that there's been a lot more
silence you know you will you have very
I mean voices that I've often disagreed
with Tucker Carlson speaking out but you
know he's uh unfortunate a rare voice
compared to everyone else that is out
there we need yeah isn't it I don't know
this is your point uh isn't that
interesting Tucker Carlson he's
defending a Muslim now right right right
we may have had our disagreement I don't
remember if I've been on his show I
don't think so but but I've been on
other Fox News shows and really I want
to thank Tucker for speaking out because
very principled that is a principal
position and it makes perfect sense and
it's important I think more in the media
speak out you know Romania has to be
taught a lesson this isn't this isn't
acceptable just like we did when when
that that uh lesbian football player uh
was arrested for having some THC honor
which is ironic because right now I have
criminal defense uh clients who are
arrested for the same thing facing
felony charges so again even in the U.S
you know minorities are going to jail
for these things and and overseas we've
helped people get out for these things
but the point is more political pressure
more media pressure and and really we
ask people in the position of influence
globally to do what they can because I'm
afraid of the chilling effect we don't
want this message that you know uh a
popular person becomes Muslim and then
just within days almost he's thrown in
jail and the world isn't able to do
anything and then the next person in the
position of influence is afraid to speak
out and the reality is let's let's be
real
you know everyone's got some sort of
skeleton in their closet I'm not saying
you know I certainly don't believe the
accusations are true but no one is
perfect especially if you've grown up as
a non-muslim you've been you know
drinking and clubbing and this and that
you know the re in fact even in the U.S
let's be real there's so many felony
crimes on the books that they say the
average uh American commits at least
three felonies so it's I don't want this
idea out there that if you Embrace Islam
they can come after you and destroy you
and the ummah will not stand with you we
have to stand United as an ummah for
justice as Muslims but even non-muslims
as people who uh are committed to the
rule of law and Justice we have to stand
for the principles of Liberty and
Justice and demand due process in the
case of the Tates yeah and we've also
this is a very important point because
it's not just because Andrew Tay we've
also spoken out you have also you have
other people afia Siddiki for instance
that's the whole difference it's a
heartbreaking case that's a woman now
it's a heartbreaking case and honestly
shame on the Pakistani government
for not taking an active role
in seeking her freedom in fact they
played the opposite role and in the
gospel Allah in the decade after 9 11.
so many Muslims were sold literally sold
to the US government
for money you know five thousand ten
thousand dollars ahead some just
recently released from Guantanamo after
decades
without charges it's a reminder that
this Dunya is a test because the
Injustice that happened especially
towards the Muslim Community in the in
the decades since 9 11 is heartbreaking
and enraging
um and obviously I mean she's been in
horrible conditions right now
incarcerated in Texas
um again the charges don't make sense
the evidence doesn't support it she
herself uh victim of of Injustice of
torture of abuse a well-respected sister
you have heard you have Imam Amin you
know also facing false charges and
decades in jail
you have the Holy Land Foundation
yeah individuals we spoke with uh about
this exactly I mean they they supported
Charities of the U.N and the U.S Aid was
supporting but they've been locked up
some of them for decades so you know
Allah we ask Allah to make us a means of
Liberty of Justice For Humanity and we
can't have a positive impact I mean here
in Florida we had Imam of Toba you know
I visited him in jail he was locked up
because his legs were Unchained he was
Bloody you know uh facing 20 years in
jail allegedly for supporting terrorism
and the community was scared to stand
with alhamdul we stood with him and
through Allah took the stand and told
the judge your honor if you're going to
keep him in jail for 20 years may as
well take me and every other Muslim
because with the evidence you're using
against him could apply to all of us
possession of Islamic books uh
supporting the Quran I said just lock us
all up then you just destroy rip the
Constitution and pieces lock us all up
alhamdulillah the judge released him and
if you speak to Imam utawah now and I
think a legal experts a lot of them say
had we not been as a community
courageous enough to stand with him and
take the stand he might still be in jail
to this day we have to stand against
Injustice be fearless and remember the
greatest act of striving in the path of
Allah is to speak truth to tyranny and
that's what we do inshallah as devout
Muslims as Muslim lawyers and we'll
continue to do so we ask Allah to Grant
Justice and Liberty to the Tate brothers
and to all those that are wrongfully
incarcerated and make us a means of
Peace Justice and guidance in this world
thank you brother it's always a pleasure
to have you likewise
you can't take it with you when you go
or you can't take this with you when you
go and you can't take this with you when
you go brothers and sisters we're all
going to depart from this life and all
of our material possessions to our money
will stay behind but your reoccurring
investment in the dean Center will
continue to grow even when you leave
this light so go ahead and make that
reoccurring investment in a Masjid Mega
dollar Center that will benefit you in
this life and in the next click the link
below donate right now may God Almighty
Allah reward all of you
cannot leave without giving you a gift
if you are not yet Muslim and you tune
in to see what these Muslims are talking
about and you like a free copy of the
Quran go and visit thedineshow.com we'll
take care of the postage and everything
and get it delivered to you and if you
still have some questions
about Islam call us at
1-800-662-4752 we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you